[Applaudissements]
morgane le grain 21 ans n'est pas
rassuré lauréate du concours du meilleur
berger en franche comté
elle affronte aujourd'hui quarante
concurrents pour les nationales première
épreuve de la journée
un quiz de 15 questions s'enchaînent
huit minutes plus tard la deuxième
épreuve avec la reconnaissance des races
ovines baisse a dit que la première
s'est complètement planté blanc comme ça
on aurait pu croire que c'était un saint
mais les chaudières est en fait pas du
tout star romaine
donc là déjà on tombe de haut et puis
les autres ça a été à peu près sauf le
dernier
il doit y avoir trois erreurs étudiante
en licence professionnelle terroir aline
il de mamirolle morgan voue une
véritable passion pour le métier de
berger qu'elle a découvert un peu par
hasard tombé sur une personne vraiment
passionné
bien qu'il ait encore daniel et je
retourne chez lui 1 c'est souvent parce
que
c'est tout ce qu'il a
cette quantité
on fait tout ce qu'il est
un peu d'endurance paris rappelle mes
temps
c'est jamais bien se faire plus mais
sinon ça va le format du leur
moi à une amie ouais morgane n'est pas
la seule jeune franc comtoise à avoir
choisi cette voie fanny 21 ans de
servance en haute saône et éleveuse
depuis l'âge de 16 ans elle aussi passer
un concours au salon de l'agriculture
dans la catégorie vaches vosgiennes pas
de stress c'est pas comme si on donnait
du mal pour toi il ya toujours moyen
c'est surtout bien pour une moindre
[Musique]
et forcément dans ce milieu un peu rude
la question de la féminité s'invite
naturellement dans la conversation des
deux jeunes filles
quand on a l'envié de s'installer ou
même de travail et je comprenais pas ça
au sérieux parce qu'on est déçus parce
qu'on est hors cadre familial et je
pense que c'est pareil dans les moutons
que c'est que nous les vaches ont déjà
fait pour faire tout son projet de ton
projet et ou quand tu vas voir les
marketeux rien ce n'est ni mieux ni elle
permettrait pourtant il va s'installer
[Musique]
on n'en parle plus mais on repart des
épreuves elles se poursuivent avec le
parage c'est bien c'est un pote tu
bouges page
[Applaudissements]
ça fait un léger par hp ou la mettre sur
des soirées dire de toute façon c'est la
meilleure vous avez rien à m'apprendre
parce que déjà ça le fait pas et puis
c'est pas vrai toujours à prendre
n'importe quel âge
et puis moi j'aime bien quand on
explique quand on m'explique comme ça
n'était pas allé assez loin tu peux
encore c'est comme ça qu'on va commencer
18 heures passées les résultats tombent
dans le brouhaha total manga n'entend
pas son nom elle s'est malheureusement
classées entre la 11e et la 40e place
[Applaudissements]
c'est qu'on tente de ranimer la vallée
des services ne sais pas
le classement c'est super émotif c'est
c'est super l'expérience fonctionne
c'est avoir la chance de participer
profitez en france 30% des bergers sont
des femmes
ceux qui ont fait le métier agricole le
plus féminisé la raison le côté fibre
maternelle qu'il convient d'avoir pour
élever et soigner les bêtes dans une
nature envers des animaux vraiment mais
transmet nyala